this is the technical difficulties we're
playing citation needed joining me today
who reads books you know it's Chris Joel
I hope everybody's favorite Gary Brown
Gary Brannen gone free as free as your
mum blow
[Applause]
and the bouncy smell on this stage Matt
gray hello you
in front of me I've got an article from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact they get right is a point and
a ding and the special prize property
advantage which in oh yeah what have we
done and today we are talking about the
ice block expedition of 1959 this is a
slight kink not holding back the tide
trying to stop it melting by sheer force
whose will well this is part this is the
problem with the expeditions they
couldn't find enough people called Bill
will and William or Willis to take along
which is why it failed which is where
the ice caps are still melting
oh well us that's called the alveolar
bread mecca nuns and they're all too
warm no sorry Pierce drowns to do that
we're all cold
what offer the lover look if you got
bread making and you got warm and you
need a warm ants to activate the yeast
if you've got cold and you got pierced
American hands because that keeps the
pastry cold and the butter doesn't melt
dick
[Applause]
so if you've got bread making and you
can melt [ __ ] yes
you're like a superhero ever
I'm a new hand man bell end melter
somebody appear for that thing is you
know this was a publicity stunt in fact
it was called the biggest publicity
stunt the world had ever seen
was this a beverage company trying to
serve their drinks with Arctic ice for
something like I'm gonna give you a
point for Arctic ice cuz it was started
so this is a no isn't it there's like a
teacher at school yes has anyone else
got any suggestions what you're right
about Arctic ice but it was not a
beverage company was it one of these mad
things where they're gonna like irrigate
the Kalahari or something okay um it
wasn't it wasn't irrigation but it was
an attempt to get an ice block from the
Arctic Circle to the equator for the
lulz fish for the publicity just kill a
cool box how BIG's your cool box I mean
I know you eat octopi so what kind of
company would want to do a publicity
stunt by moving ice all that distance
over land to the equate all the land
over that over land a fridge company
holy to show the beneficiary of that or
asbestos company sure they're good that
fast nothing it's not asbestos but it's
it's it's industry my giving us points
saying it's my parents say yeah it's a
Norwegian insulation company will give
you any viewpoint kill if there wasn't
asbestos in that I'll be very surprised
and frankly if there is a specialist in
it they will have been very super not
until about 25 years later it was made
from glass wool made from fiberglass yes
this was inspired by a radio station in
1958 which radio station would have put
up a challenge like that the BBC World
Service it the ITV will
what run up in the walkies what would
the ITV World Service be because that's
basically just less amount and deck yeah
to be fair that sounds like something
Anton deck would be ITV on today would
do now one day we're gonna transport a
block of ice to the acquittal I've
stripped over two weeks with a nude vote
off which bit of ice you don't like and
you're a TV commissioners 25% yeah now
you say it's a radio station may have
been Yara one let's be on a boat well it
was something beyond our borders
it was Radio Luxembourg ah who launched
a challenge to transport three tonnes of
ice from the Arctic Circle to the
equator let's say this if anyone does it
yeah and then it's one those awful
things where someone turns up on your
doorstep with three tonnes of ice from
the Arctic wacky radio challenge what
was the prize they were going to award
for this okay someone who works in red
garnet load atomic I mean you could buy
it you could buy that with this free
drinks all round more ice 1 million
dollars
Oh 100,000 throw you doing it again no
no no I'm getting there I'm getting
there
No what is this her kilo that made it to
the arches so theoretically that was
anything up to 300 million francs if
I've done my math right but if someone
actually managed to get the three tonnes
of ice there and suddenly Oh an
insulation companies got involved they
started being very worried yeah how did
they get the ice out of the office take
a digger or something you know and
you've got an ice lolly and you lick one
bit and it goes in you they're just
ridiculous well Oh erm Norwegian men
hands in these
haha can you not do that your mom's n
they they ought to get out out from a
glacier in two hundred kilo blocks what
are they used what you use to remove
that much on spoon big bananas um no no
chainsaw I knew you get that is you have
a chainsaw license don't not since
October ah
whether you're all slightly safer in
your bed look when we have that absinthe
and chainsaw night last week you told me
you will fully qualifies uh once you're
drunk you don't need to be qualified you
are becomes much more natural to be fair
I don't think Leatherface from the
horror movies really had a license no
that's not a requirement
yeah but let me see what happened you
see what is that like Al Capone is that
well they got him on ha ha so yes 200
kilo blocks melted together to make a
single block of ice weighing 3050 kilos
or um now I'm setting this up
specifically for Gary
what was the container they constructed
it made from iron correct they're two
little squirrels that Distiller the
squirrels in my head when we're saying
say I and the other side say anything
else oh uh yes they placed on top a
truck that would carry it all the way to
the equator accompanied by what two of
every animal gin in a big tanker behind
it as per a film crew
sadly where did they go they start the
assaulter well yes okay pause points
because I'm not in your point that they
started it started near the r12 in the
Arctic Circle where no way out Norway
yes Oh cheating bastards
how is that cheating I don't know a
decent thing that they got all the way
to the North Pole and another Arctic
Circle to equator
all right I have it in my head I'd image
of an iron tank with the North Pole
sticking out I was kind of siding you
can just get a budget flight to the
artic yeah yeah but can you imagine to
carry on for three and three tons of ice
slice it in one in each seat just have
refrigerated pockets of a fish invest
and save bit by bit that's how you get
past Ryanair shark yes yes where all the
ice yeah so the first stop was Oslo
which seems a sensible place yeah what
would be needed in the near the equator
at Libreville where they finished food
not quite certain something that was
needed for people live they seemed young
Addison Matt gets the point absolutely
right on 300 kilos of medicines are
going to so obviously they can keep them
cold
they got us God I didn't think of using
the ice to transport something I thought
he just met something else that was
along for the ride no that medicines go
off in the heat so suddenly they had a
lot of ice within it was there a horror
from beyond time that is yet to be won
frozen as well half a flying saucer yeah
goddamn stop just carried on cutting
with a chainsaw hey there's another one
I hate seven joke up but you mums it Hey
okay oh she is it Nora
um what happened in Belgium the customs
yeah absolutely right what what they not
have ice right a license to carry out
yeah absolutely write it in a Buster's
declaration for it
concealed-carry for an ice cube sorry
sir I can see you are dripping there
yeah absolutely right
there was no customs declaration for the
ice are you in fear it's tons of ice it
was so how do you solve something like
that defense it's disguise it as a
circus no just a mustache and a stick on
those and this is Steve
hurry up Steve he don't say much I know
our customs official just accompanied
them all the way so officially it never
entered Belgium to make sure they didn't
import illegal ice yes wait wait what if
a Belgian run up and had a lick why is
it with me a licking she see me in the
freezer you shouldn't see me freezing
that's why yeah that's why you're banned
from Iceland isn't it both the country
and the super keepers on the recursive
nature if they had a branch of Iceland I
did it we just call it England yes
the freezers don't work and everything's
twice as expensive as it was a month ago
satire yeah I'm big odds Paris are the
the crew were invited to dine with the
president are the mayor I'll give you a
point that's enough
[Music]
Gary I'm the scale of Savita year War II
the do you want the point
I don't want [ __ ] points right down
at the bottom you have mare or peer you
have lip resonance I was talking the
cheese by the way all right I think
dinner with no yeah the president got
[ __ ] never get you into international
diplomacy I think none of us should ever
be an international diplomacy fair cop
yeah um yes repair as they continue to
Marseille and it was lifted aboard a
freighter that sailed to Algiers how
much water had melted by the point they
got to the Sahara no I felt into water
you're not have a biscuit um how much
ice had melted by the time they got it
to to the 20% and oh it's a good
fraction loser can't be wrong now
well Gary wins well the thing to know
you're actually close it was only four
liters out of all about less than one
thousandth so about one shall he say
anything did no say no to that you said
zero to you closer you by sudden that's
undefinable we got any mathematicians in
course we've got some mathematicians
beautiful point Chris gets the point
bastard what were the instructions they
got as they went across the Sahara go
west
their life is peaceful Oh Matt I know
you're not good at directions if he was
doing directions you'd have said go
right left what was the main danger in
the Sahara at that point being shot Oh
yet again Chris absolutely right so they
were at war on uh there was there were
forces hiding in the mountain did we
start it huh did we start it we weren't
even alive Matt I don't think any of us
could've started the advice was no stops
drive for your lives even if you get a
flat tire
cool you see they don't have that in the
driving test other maybe if you go to
Saharan Africa they do to be fair that
was a wonderful question outside of a
theory test last year yeah and one of
the questions is what do you do if you
are driving through a tunnel but your
car is on fire but your car is still
drivable get the [ __ ] out the tunnel yes
yeah you're absolutely right I'm 88 your
cars drive we'll get out cuz otherwise
you gonna kill other people I'm gonna be
that honest I don't want that to happen
to anybody ever which that look good
[Music]
just good in out of a tunnel in flames
are you going I'm doing good
and here's where you're listening to
Matt Monro and as a bulldozer at the far
end anyway you're gonna have to Wow
five people here have seen the Italian
so you've driven your burning car out of
the tunnel then you gotta somehow get
out of it with the most panache you can
yeah I wouldn't be worried about panache
at that point as we all know the driving
test is rated on style control damage of
the ground okay so
so just just the reference Italian job
no Robot Wars yes yes we've found our
level can I ask you a question yes what
were we talking about
they were devised a Lada Samara
they were sourcing Zara on the aliquot
expedition of 1959 they had taken a
block of ice
from the Arctic Circle they made the
Sahara they met a tribe that lived there
and how they greet them what do they
give them uh for hugs what a pistol
fight bit one-sided but you know yeah
yeah close water yes absolutely right
they gave the camels water from the
container
um the commentary in a camel get his
toes stuck to the big boy device I
believe they had a small spigot on the
bottom that could drain Oh good use of
the words bigger target what would be in
the water give him what it's insulated
oh happy burglar yes but in the entire
trip across the Arctic they lost how
much water eight Lisa's ten say any no
camels worth Oh Chris jets at ninety six
liters
it's about camels what matters and who
they meet we're looking for a UH a very
famous physician dr. Jones dr. Jones
[Music]
what I like is that you could hear the
ripple of people getting down and about
I know Albert Schweitzer I have never
heard that or Isabel for some reason but
I don't know why I gemin theologian
organist philosopher and physician is
organist a subcategory of physician what
you'd Norway send to Schweitzer's
hospital supplies I'm supply yet okay
I'll need you to narrow that down cuz
the water melted some fish to swim in it
oh no picks up fish Gary you keep
accidentally saying something that's
close enough
what wouldn't always send half a ton of
fish because what kind what kind of
pickled herring ahahahaha
there we go close enough art click Fisk
ah no that's right that actually other
urn from someone who left only eaten
that in the audience
Dryden salted cod he's in the middle of
the Sahara yeah he's got a doctor said
middle of Sahara yeah and Norway think
it's Gabon so they're all the bars okay
go but Norway thinks it's cool to send a
lot of very salty fish to a very dry
part of the world yeah yeah what about I
bet that smell nice in 50 degree heat
but what's in the box you've been
waiting for months for this
[Music]
what is wrong with them first of all
they made it that's the important thing
they got there it was called the
greatest publicity stunt of all time
they delivered 90% of that ice without
melting to Libreville a representative
of the the insulation company met them
in Libreville oh yeah with them no
haven't taken the short route I'm Howard
uh he was a friend of someone and we
talked about him earlier and you got a
point despite the fact you shouldn't
have the mayor of Paris oh yeah that was
where I won't say assets but all I got
was a half-court shot an exhale through
the air and it's sales with the aromatic
just bounced off the rim
yes what Tom never use the phrase off
the rim it's like arrows wanna get the
point about zip ties it done absolutely
right our president Charles de Gaulle
was a friend of that did he fly there I
want the champ all night
[Music]
yes um he came with an offer what what
did the represent of that company say to
thee to the expedition that had got all
the way there that had found that the
guy that got the ice got it there almost
entirely intact what time he call it
could you just Bob it back up to Paris
for us he said that if the crew were
willing to drive it back to Paris the
president himself would receive them
under the Arc de Triomphe receive is not
a euphemism in freedom or so you think
what did they say to offer right they
were exhausted they said no they said
that is it they flew home they left the
ice there with the citizens and it was
called the greatest publicity stunt of
order did they then properly go around
really or look Sandberg's front door
rapped on the door with a bill Radio
Luxembourg withdrew the offer what for
tradition is set up you've got their
Radio Luxembourg I believe I'm rich uh
to be fair they did withdraw it 1dx
before the expedition set off when it
was being planned they said they were
just joking that wasn't what they had in
mind unless the radio show has never
done that this and on that note everyone
here gets free mystery biscuits good
luck uh-huh on that congratulations Gary
you win the show
[Applause]
and I'm breathing great Thank You win at
all around a giant underground
laboratory designed to accelerate
flatulence close to the speed of light
no no no it's a fastball accelerator
with that we say thank you to Chris Cole
here Alan
I've been Tom Scott and we will see you
after we walk off pretend it's the end
of the show and walk by shot again
[Applause]
[Music]
you